oh [ __ ] how did i forget how did i
forget this yeah let's
shout out to the boy caring shout out to
carrington from love island
you know you never think you're we're so
removed from the [ __ ] show you know
these people are isolated on an island
so we just talk [ __ ] and then afterwards
i get out and they
see it and so they [ __ ] message us i
had carrington message me
and it was a it was a video on instagram
of him watching that's grinch he was
watching the horse
one yeah and he was laughing at it and
then the caption said
um said something about it was like i
love you guys
like y'all are so funny even though and
then my my broken screen cut it off so i
couldn't read it
yeah so i was like i was like lemaio
like what did we say
and he just said he just said nah i just
said i love you guys even though
noel called me a fish with teeth well he
hit me up this morning
and he's like and he was like you didn't
say anything though
so like no no it's like whatever but i
love your guys's humor i have the same
sense of humor
so it was litty to see that yeah he hit
me up this morning
uh um
i said cody told me you heard all my
roasting so now i gotta own it
he said i thought it was funny as hell i
always watch tmg haha nice
let me just say hey
[Music]
you should come on the podcast bro yeah
yeah let's do it
yeah that'd be fun well so i asked him i
said you move are you
in la he said nah i'm in utah but i'm
going to look at spots in la
thinking about moving there and i'm like
dude everyone's leaving bro everyone's
going to utah
yeah everyone what do you mean yeah
wrong direction yeah
i mean no dude sorry go ahead no this
whole scenario just gave me an idea for
like
um a separate podcast where
we confront everyone we've ever trashed
on a reality tv show
um you know it's been a while i feel
like it's easy like
you get you provide the context up front
it's like there's like a 20 minute
15 minute prologue where you and i kind
of bounce back and explain what the [ __ ]
and then for 45 minutes you know we get
we get mackenzie from love island and be
like hey
who was that again the one i called
crazy she was
oh mackenzie oh the blonde one yeah oh
my god yeah i mean she literally is
crazy yeah we just created a train wreck
out of that yeah
we bring like caller crazy on the air
yeah her and connor no we don't call her
crazy on there
they'll be they're dating now i know oh
i'm like super dating i know she is
there must be something
she wants to have something for that
dude to just walk off television and be
like i love you i love you i love you i
like straight to her like he was
hypnotized
yeah it's because he like wasn't
experienced nice yeah
gorilla grip notice yeah yeah
grypnitized
that's what it is when you got that
[ __ ] wet that that
wet wet grypnotized
that's when you get guys going to grip
you guys going i love mommy i love my
mommy
yeah do you dude i love my mommy
so i won't mommy's go with
whip no a woven mommy puts a good wheel
with whip on me
they they're they're actually perfect
together yeah
yeah you know i'm going through their
instagram pictures i'm like [ __ ] this
makes so much sense i mean they look
they legitimately look so happy
yeah he's just a submissive guy yeah
that's fine she's a
she's a dominant one dominant kind of
crazy woman you know what i'm saying i'm
not
saying dominant women are crazy i'm
saying she's a mix of both
and so it weirdly works it killed me how
when he gets nervous
he couldn't find enough moisture to talk
yeah
i always felt like the um and this is a
funky ass thing to say but i don't care
i always felt like his his mouth was
disproportionate to his face
okay like he'd always be licking his
lipstick but he had like the
like the tongue of like a shih tzu like
it was just like so
you know what i'm saying like he
couldn't moisturize his mouth
to talk to her when you get nervous yeah
you always you're like i just think yeah
stop you're you're ruining people's
saturdays sorry
they're not even listening anymore the
headphones are crushed after knowing
that
you'll see has a dude i'm picturing a
dude
hearing that and just taking his [ __ ]
air pods out just
throwing them at the wall yeah his skull
candy yes
[ __ ] having a skull candy um
they're still around yeah yeah they're
in gas stations
um but absolutely we should get
carrington on the podcast yeah
and because shout out to shout out to
you i mean
regardless the season was what i told
him the season was really fun to watch
yeah and they made it [ __ ] great no
that you know what i'm saying it's like
after the show you don't really care if
someone was
sh and he wasn't even that shitty i mean
he's i think he's still dating that girl
no
he yeah he is and he was like by the end
of it you get you
see what kind of dude he was like oh
he's just he's not idiot he's just
straight up
yeah like he's just that comfortable
that he's like yeah i'm exotic
but it's weird how after the show when
when they're back in just a normal life
how you know where everything isn't
under a lens anymore yeah you're kind of
like oh yeah these people aren't these
people are actually more normal
than i thought like seeing connor and
mckenzie together now i'm like yeah it
makes sense and even
when on the show i was like this [ __ ]
is the last relationship that should
exist
yeah yeah i mean it's crazy it's it's
actually wild all of us would look crazy
yeah yeah i mean it's all editing and
i'm sure the producers are like hey
yeah she said yeah he said that being
said that mckenzie actually is crazy
i'm not backing down from that i got
such a nasty dm over that [ __ ]
what did they say it was like you're
this
and you probably endorsed cheating
connor cheated on her
at castle moore and you probably tell
your friends okay
i was like wait what yeah yeah we yeah
we
we're big cheating endorsers yeah bro we
we like to endorse cheating publicly
that's i was like guys guys you know
real guys guys
yo let's talk about that yeah well i
just i just had to say
i don't know how you could watch that
and not objectively think oh man this
this girl got a screw loose i know i
don't know how you don't think that
yeah i mean she was manipulative yeah
that's the thing
yeah yeah anyone who's who's like that
i feel like there's a certain part of
their brain that's like you know
maybe it's something about being like
narcissist or something yeah where you
see
parts of people that you can take
advantage of and you do it yeah even
though you're
maybe you're not even realizing you're
doing it maybe it's just it's how you
are yeah i kind of feel like really
manipulative people because we're
watching
the vow on hbo do i tell you about that
show no it's about nixium the
nexium the sex cult the guy left
literally yeah yeah no yeah i wanted to
start that
yeah dude it's unfucking yeah yeah don't
tell me yeah
i won't tell you anything about it but
the guy the guy just got conv it's like
super recent right yeah like over the
last three years the guy just got
convicted yesterday
it was a there's like a uh nbc like
tweet or whatever
sick um but yeah so we're watching this
and since it happened so recently
there's like so much footage because the
guy the guy had a filmer there
and any time he did anything 247 he had
a filmer with him
so you get to see everything that he did
right and so you get to see him
manipulating people
lives and i always think like people
like that do they just have a moment
where they're
whether when they're younger where
they'd say something
maybe off the cuff they're like i'll
just try this they say something and the
person
you know goes yeah i'll do that for you
and they're like wait
yeah this works it worked yeah that
little thing yeah
it's like a little secret formula now i
can just use that over and over again to
take advantage of people and have them
do things for me i think that's actually
like an actual
i know the word social pack is thrown
out around a lot i feel like that's a
genuine
sociopath trait yeah to realize
that you can control people and so you
use your charm to do that
yeah to get what you want yeah thing but
yeah
yeah it could be a narc thing i don't
know but yeah
i meant to bring that up when we were
first talking about love island
that was just i don't know anyway which
this is
the the message was was wild oh that dm
i'm pretty sure it was mckenzie's burner
like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah this is
big a non-profile
yeah she's like i'll have you know
actually yeah it was shitty to me i mean
mackenzie yeah yeah now that i'm
thinking about it that's completely
it was just a mckenzie stand just going
off on me
i'm surprised they didn't hit me the
full paragraph they're like anyway stan
kenzie and then just like 80
fan cams of mckenzie there's fan cams
for everything dude
i know it's wild we can get the tim high
decker thing in a second but god damn
i've i saw fan cam the other day they
just had me
i mean i thought formula i thought
formula one drivers was like
the peak of there's no i can't remember
but it's it was something that just had
me like
there's a good one that someone sent me
a while back an ironic
fan cam of the [ __ ] formula one
safety car okay
is that the one that like tags behind
it's yeah or like like if there's like a
crash or something it like pulls out in
front and it's like so random yeah it i
don't know
it killed me it was like stan's safety
car that's really funny
it's like [ __ ] that's really funny the
tokyo drift song is
oh that's good damn yeah that's so good